you are 300 times less likely to be
audited by the IRS when you have a
business entity in place as an
entrepreneur you deserve to have privacy
you don't have to have your address
listed on your State website there's
ways that we can make that private for
you by utilizing registered Agents from
A Loss standpoint any of those expenses
that you've already made the phone the
internet the power the camera capture
those as business related expenses to
make those dedu
as you start to generate income usually
we'll say $50 to
$100,000 or more we can simply change
the LLC so that it's taxed as an escort
that then allows you to pay yourself a
salary but it also allows you to avoid
half of your self-employment tax saving
you about 7%